[inaudible]
Greek fire was a sort
of medieval flame store,
which was using combat and helped the
Byzantine Empire Win many battles and
century weapons had been using history
beforehand. Of course by the Assyrians,
Romans, Chinese, and others hovered
Greek fire. We came about the 672 AED.
According to Theo,
upon of Colleen and coasts,
the weapon proves very useful in Byzantium
swore that the Arabs and assassin and
Persians were gradually
weakening the empire.
The weapon had its debut in a siege of
Constantinople and 674 and the Arabs
under Kalief.
He has the,
the first attempted to invade and
control the Santiam teams, Capitol City,
Constantinople.
However,
Greek fire was responsible primarily
for destroying the Arab fleet,
thus securing victory after four years.
Greek fire was also used when the Arabs
came back in 700 1880 it was also,
he was against the vikings,
Bulgarians and in the Byzantine
civil war because secure victory.
Okay.
The Arabs attempts to coffee the weapon,
however they were
unsuccessful in doing so,
the composition of the weapon was a
secret and remains so. To this day,
it requires several parts
to correctly operate in.
Different people were assigned
to operate different parts,
meaning even the sea foam. Now
Roy, the Byzantine inflame flowers,
we're not sure if how it worked. What
historians and chemists do know though,
is that the substance as a liquid,
it burns on water.
It produced a large amount of smoke
was not easily extinguishable.
Most historians agree that it was based
on petroleum, much like modern napalm,
a crude oil,
not as NAPFA was readily available to
the Byzantines along with resident being
added to the mixture. Now, the truth
about the composition remains a mystery.
It may for a very long time.
Okay?
From our videos on technology
history of much more,
I would invite you to subscribe
and check out my channel. Also,
this video has made possible by the
support of Byzantine ball on Facebook for
humorous content about
the Byzantine Empire.
I would encourage you to like their page.
Thank you for watching.